>> Okay, I enabled reports.
>> Yep.
>> I just want to make one of these
charts though, make my Gauge, my Gauge Monitor.
>>
[LAUGH]
Well, we're almost there.
>> Okay, so, New Report. Now I'll search for attendees again.
>> And there it is.
>> Festivals with Attendees.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, Create. Alright, and this is again?
>> It's a lot to look at, at first.
So, think of a report at it's lowest common denominator.
>> Mm-hm.
>> It's just like a spreadsheet.
>> Okay.
>> So down here in the little preview area.
>> Yeah.
>> This is going to show you some of the records. Not all
of them. Like, right now it's showing festival
name, attending names. It's not showing you all
of them. It's just doing a little preview
of what the report would look like now.
>> Okay.
>> So, on the left side bar, you
can drag all of those different fields, which are
fields on festival and attendee into your report, so
we can see summarized data about those two objects.
>> So, what would dragging a field be? If I dragged in.
>> Well, what's something we care about in our Gauge report?
>> Money.
>> Right.
>> Total Spent.
>> So, grab that off of the Attendee object.
>> Okay, and there's just a few places where I could drag it, does it matter?
>> you could put it anywhere. And you could
keep dragging and dropping, reordering this as you go.
>> Okay. Okay, I get it. So this is basically
a spreadsheet and I'm just choosing which columns to show.
>> Exactly. So let's pick a couple other
fields like. What are a couple of other
fields that you might want to show in this
report? Like maybe they wouldn't necessarily come up
on the Dashboard or the graph that we're trying to show, but if you were to hand
off this report to an executive or a
manager, what are things they would care about seeing?